- [Voiceover] Let's see
if we can figure out
what 256 to the four-sevenths power,
divided by two to the
four-sevenths power is,
and like always, pause the
video and see if you can
figure this out.
All right, let's work
through this together,
and at first you might
find this kind of daunting.
Especially when you see
something like two to the
four-sevenths power or is that even,
that's not going to be a
whole number, how do I,
how do I do this, especially
without a calculator.
And I should've said, do
this without a calculator.
But then the key is to
see that we can use our
exponent properties to
simplify this a little bit
so that we can do this on paper.
And the main property
that may jump out at you
is if I have something, if I have,
if I have x to the a power, over y
to the a power, this is
the same thing as x over y,
to the a power.
And in our situation right over here,
256 would be x, two would be y,
and then a is four-sevenths,
so we can rewrite this,
this is going to be equal to
this is equal to 256, over two,
to the four-sevenths
power, and so this is nice.
We're already able to simplify this,
because we know 256
divided by two, is 128.
So this is 128 to the four-sevenths power.
Now this might also seem
a little bit difficult,
how do I raise 128 to a fractional power?
But we just have to remind ourselves,
this is the same thing, this
is the same thing as 128
to the one-seventh power.
Then raised to the fourth power.
We could also view it the
other way around, we could say
that this is also 128 to the fourth,
to the fourth power, and
then raise that to the
one-seventh, but
multiplying 128 four times,
that's going to be very
computationally intensive,
and then you have to find
the seventh root of that.
That seems pretty difficult,
so we don't want to
go in that way, but if we can
get the smaller number first,
what is 128 to the one-seventh power?
Then that might be easier to
raise to the fourth power.
Now when you look at this,
and knowing that probably,
the question writer in this
case, I'm the person who
presented it with you is,
telling you that you're not
going to use a calculator is,
it's a pretty good clue that,
all right, this is probably going to be a,
this is probably going to
be something that I can
figure out on my own,
and you might recognize
128 as a power of two,
and maybe two to the seventh
is 128, and we can verify that.
So let's see, two to the first is two.
Four, eight, 16,
32, 64, 128.
Two times two is four, times two is eight,
times two is 16, times
two is 32, times 2 is 64,
times two is 128.
So, two to the seventh power
is equal to 128, or another way of saying
this exact same thing is that 128,
128 is equal to
or 128 to the one-seventh power,
is equal to two.
Or you could even say
that the seventh root,
the seventh root of 128, is equal,
is equal to two.
So, we can simplify this.
This is two, so our whole
expression is now just
two to the fourth power.
Well, that's just two times two,
times two, times two.
So, that's two to the fourth power.
Two to the fourth power, which is just
going to be equal to 16.
That's two, times two, times two, times
two, right over there.
And so we're done!
This crazy,
complicated-looking expression,
it is simplified
to 16.